Is Math Art?
Of course it is!
Why would you even... that's a dumb question.
Hey guys, Tara Long here for Dnews today - to
talk about one of my favorite subjects, math.
Which as it turns out - is as valid a form
of art, as any other.
who knew?
Now it's difficult to put into words, exactly
what it is that makes numbers and symbols
so appealing - but according to scientists,
it boils down to simple brain chemistry.
In a recent study at University College in
London, researchers showed a group of mathematicians
60 different mathematical equations, and asked
them to rate those equations on a scale of
"ugly to "beautiful," while inside an fMRI
scanner.
The results showed that the more "beautiful"
an equation was - according to the test subject
- the more likely it was to elicit activity
in the A1 field of the medial orbitofrontal
cortex.
This is the part of your brain that's typically
associated with emotional responses to visual
and musical beauty.
Meaning people like us respond to numbers
and equations, the same way other people do
to music or art.
But even people with no musical talent can
still appreciate good music - so what constitutes
beauty in math?
And does the appreciation of it require some
understanding of its meaning?
Well, not necessarily.
To test that idea, researchers performed the
same study on a control group - with no special
appreciation of math.
And while those subjects did show a significantly
lower emotional response to the equations
- a handful of them were still capable of
finding their beauty - even with no understanding
of what they actually mean.
So what makes an equation "objectively beautiful"?
Is it just a formula of curves and shapes,
maybe symmetry that makes it pleasing to the
eye?
It's difficult to quantify the exact reasons,
but there is one equation consistently rated
to be the most attractive - and that's Euler's
identity (1+eiπ=0) - perhaps because it contains
the 3 most fundamental numbers in the mathematical
universe, e, pi, and i.
It's a pretty hot equation, I'm not gonna
lie.
What's the ugliest, you ask?
According to the mathematicians in this study,
it's this - Srinivasa Ramanujan's rapidly
converging infinite series of π.
But hey - there's a lot about math I don't
know.
I'm not a wizard.
If there's an equation out there you don't
think gets enough recognition - then leave
it in the comments below.
Or tweet at me.
And I can judge it, based on its looks.
Like a nerdy hot or not.
Or Tinder for geeks.
And hey - if you've got more time to kill,
why not go check out some of the other shows
I do, like Rev3Games - or Hard Science, the
#1 destination for videos of Anthony Carboni
injuring himself.